Bitcoin as currency on the Internet
peer-to-peer managed by the participants
in it is the perfect libertarian
solution to the money Enigma hi I'm
Nicolas we with reason TV and today
we're talking with George Gilder from
Freedom Fest 2014 in Las Vegas George
Gilder is the author most recently of
knowledge and power he is lately
passionate about Bitcoin so we're going
to find out what's turning him on about
this crypto currency George thanks for
talking to us great to be here you know
you have a history of being ahead of the
curve you helped start the Reagan
Revolution the supply-side revolution
with books like wealth and poverty you
were way ahead of the curve on the
telecom puter you know which turned into
the internet about how when things get
really small and you know they get more
and more powerful in the telecom 'some
now you are absolutely passionate about
Bitcoin what was your aha moment that
you okay Bitcoin is is that the deal of
the future well I just written knowledge
and power about information theory and I
figured that Shannon's information
theory because was perfect instrument
for creating a network that could
efficiently transmit transmit bits and
bytes however to have a civilization you
need more than just bits and bytes you
need contracts you need transactions you
need provable facts you need titles you
need notarization you need identities
you need all these other factors that
really can't be accommodated very well
on the internet so you have to have
banks and all these other outside
channels to conduct transactions you
have this comedy of bogus contracts as
we were supposed to sign as you provide
yeah yeah click the button you accept
with you gratitude I mean the Internet
is full of junk right and and it
pretends that a lot of that stuff is
free which of course is a lie so it's
full of lies it's a hustle
it's a lot of the characteristics of the
Internet are the result of just having a
pure Shannon information without hire a
Shannon information Anand for Anand
identifies information exclusively by
its surprisal unexpected bits rights how
you measure information and bandwidth
across the net and it was Shannon's a
great genius and and he created the
perfect theory tick for the network
layer but as you know you need more than
three layers in the network you got to
have a whole apparatus on top of the
network in order to actually conduct a
provable transaction so how does bit
cold
well the bitcoin is a breakthrough and
information theory that allows without
reference to trusted third parties
people outside the internet to conduct
provable transactions timestamp
transactions that can't be changed and
can't be faked camp camp a fake can't be
duplicated can't be good coin is the
currency the Internet deserves it's the
currency the internet deserves and needs
and a way we have a real reality for
lack of a better term in the Internet
and now but you always had to step out
of the internet in order to get money or
it's kind of like you're at college
arrow is going hey mom sent me some
money good and now you're saying we
we've left home like the internet can
self suffice that's right in terms of
transaction and it's also a better
currency it has a wonderful insight that
the world is deflationary under
capitalist okay yeah tell us about you
know this because we hear this all the
time well deflation you know the only
thing worse than inflation is deflation
why is it a good thing that we're that
because capitalism is deflationary
capitalism is deflationary I you know I
write about learning curves I've been
writing about them for 50 years I guess
maybe sometime you'll finally get it
right
and and learning curves are the
characteristic of capitalism I have
finally gotten it right I figured out
that wealth is knowledge and you can
tell that because you know the
Neanderthal in his cave as Tom Sol wrote
years ago had all the material resources
we have today all we advanced is
increase in knowledge and growth is
learning and the reason all the
Consulting Group's when they analyze
businesses find learning curves
everywhere and what Ray Kurzweil
envisages these a singularity of
converging learning curves it's because
learning is the heart of economic growth
learning is economics it's learning I
mean it's to economize to you know so
every time we start a fire we don't have
to go through ten thousand years of
Neanderthals right right at that so
capitalism is deflationary because it
always takes it ultimately takes less
time and less resources to get things
done that's right
GARP indicator twenty to thirty percent
a year twenty to thirty percent for
every doubling a total units so learning
okay so why are people afraid of
deflation them because this is like just
because government's constantly screw up
economies causing and screw up monetary
systems and cause prices to go up and
and blame the currency so before we get
back to bitcoin though you know but then
will people invest in things if they say
oh well my house you know it's worth a
hundred grand now and in twenty years if
capitalism is working will be worth 20
grand who's going to buy a house wealth
everything around the house will have
increased and value all equipment in the
house will be enhancing your life and
whether the shell of that you erected
and 2014 will I just think it's a
meaningless question the the process by
which learning pervades the economy
produces a cornucopia what that does
is led me to the further insight about
Bitcoin yeah well okay now let's talk
about how is Bitcoin deflationary
because you know if you were lucky
enough to buy Bitcoin a few years ago
you're wealthy now especially if you
take it out of the internet and I'm like
oh she's worth of Diane bucks baby so so
how is it deflationary then or when do
we get to the point where bitcoin is no
longer a speculative currency when it
you know the speculation is is a big
debate over how what proportion of the
world's transactions Bitcoin will
essentially accommodate but bitcoin is
currently undergoing a market process
but when it reaches its full maturity
with 21 million coins which is the cap
asymptotic cap that's been imposed
through the algorithm itself which
assures that it means that that it will
tend to be deflationary the state but
not goods chasing after the same knob
yep that's right yeah but this is this
is life yeah I mean when really the
other way I came to this insight is of
the zero marginal cost society you've
heard about that that that capitalist
economics doesn't work anymore cuz we're
in a world of abundance and but money
can't be an abundant in the same way
that goods and services are good but
money has to be the foundation to
prioritize and evaluate so the question
is what is scarce when everything else
becomes abundant and what is scarce when
everything else becomes abundant is
ultimately the residual resource time
okay so how does bit now we're going for
Bitcoin two times what how does that
because the production of Bitcoin is
rigorously regulated by the passage of
time and and and the pursuit of
irreversibility
and Bitcoin is you know Satoshi all
through his original paper talks about
irreversible currency that's the big
goal and with the only thing in the
universe that's really irreversible in
this sense is time and obviously Satoshi
didn't see the first Superman movie back
in time but there is no well back in
time but then what happened I mean like
how is is it that Bitcoin is infinitely
divisible or is it I mean so we don't is
it's divisible hundred million because
in a kind of Milton Friedman wet dream
you know you would have a government or
a robot kicking out a certain amount of
predetermined expansion of money yeah
you know on a regular basis no matter
what an assumption of inflation right
and Milton Friedman was the greatest
figure in libertarian economics I don't
deny it for a minute but he did make a
major error MV equals PT that's his
great formula but the money supply times
the velocity equals output but what
we've learned overwhelmingly in recent
years is velocity is not a constant
Milton Friedman thought that the money
supply controls and because he thought
the money supply controlled he thought
you had to have some centralized control
of money and that the central body that
controlled the omission of money would
should be regulated to accommodate
economic growth which was nice he was
wrong and thinking that you need money a
growth of the money supply to have
economic yes and and that money rules
rather than velocity he thought velocity
was a constant and the money supply
could be manipulated by governments to
actually favor outcomes so and I I think
that velocity rules and velocity means
we can rule that Bitcoin as a currency
on the Internet peer to peer managed
by the participants in it is the perfect
libertarian solution and a zombie enigma
you have been you know a proselytizer
for the idea that we've can you know
continually at least in
twentieth-century terms have gone from a
totalitarian or a hierarchical society
to a hetero ARCIC oh that's right
so bitcoin is kind of like I had our
turkey yet or Ardsley Ottoman let me ask
you this though because there's so
there's the question of there's the real
world or you know what we'll call the
real world and the Internet up here
bitcoins operating up here people are
trading all around the world we've
already seen cases where the government
goes in and shuts things down and takes
Bitcoin and you know why oh you know are
we just deluding ourselves that we're in
our little happy space up here
and the minute any government wants to
they're going to come in and you know
the guys with guns you know guns you
know may not fire in cyberspace but they
don't have to so is this all just kind
of a you know a fantasy a cloud
cuckoo-land
i I think that this is an infrastructure
for the Internet the government can
always come with guns and attack our
human bodies and require us to report
everything we do with our bitcoins and
and otherwise invade our lives and
manipulate our futures and close down
our horizons but but because bitcoin is
autonomous because it's really
peer-to-peer it really is and because
it's distributed inexorably and because
it's global it's gonna I think
government will not choose to close it
down I think government will probably
decide to to say that we got a report on
our tax returns and everything that goes
on in bitcoins and moreover the
government will welcome the aspect of
Bitcoin that every transaction is
published
Rhodri that's the way it works and which
is a fascinating misconception I think
early on of Bitcoin is that it was a
great anonymous you know mechanism
because you know you just gave it away
and that was it it wasn't drawable it's
the reverse it's
that every transaction is known to
everybody in the network that's right
except that they know it as a
transaction right they and so it is cash
as it we're over it it's not it's a lot
more anonymous than submitting your
credit card and your mother's maiden
name and all the hustles we're for free
goods you have to virtually strip naked
on in front of your internet camera it's
it's like I apologize for that and I'm
not going to send that type of stuff to
you anymore okay that's a bit big really
so we're early on and kind of the
regulatory attempts to regulate Bitcoin
what do you think of the early attempts
by the IRS or the Treasury I mean it
doesn't even matter but you know I'm the
one hand is it money that or is it is it
a is it a commodity that gets taxed I
mean are these these are not important
questions to you and well I think that
it it they made the right decision that
people will buy them as buuck
participating in this speculation about
the ultimate success of Bitcoin do do
have capital gains and it's just as well
to have them you know they can you know
if we're gonna have a capital gains tax
of Bitcoin profits you know or suitably
tax through that system so I don't think
that's an outrage or an obstacle to the
success of the system a final question I
mean you you I mean you talk in a kind
of in your work over the course of your
career it's interesting I mean and here
you're very enthusiastic about this you
know an Internet where it's a
peer-to-peer distributed network that is
now building a civilization it's not
simply parallel are you thinking about
moving to the internet anytime soon if
you do well you promise to write or come
home on holidays but I say like I mean
it you know are are you talking about a
kind of singularity type of singularity
is the wrong word but like kind of a
migration to you know this electronic
distributed network and that's where
real meaning will be what real
consciousness I mean is that is that
where you're going I think
of interesting speculations and I'm
interested though now as a business
proposition I got a company that I'm
doing with Stephen spray called rivets
that's that's using the trusted platform
not the trusted platform module but a
similar kind of secure vault function to
create secure Bitcoin wallets because
the the Bitcoin system is vulnerable not
in the blockchain it's great advanced
but in all the interfaces to the
blockchain and so I think it's a great
business opportunity and so does all of
Silicon Valley think it's a great
business opportunity Marc Andreessen who
I wrote about in Forbes ASAP decades ago
is the leading new exponent of Bitcoin
and and John Doerr is finally succumbed
then there do you know there's a whole
well so what you know final final
thought how do you tell the the kind of
backward-looking reactionaries who are
like now it's all about gold it's all
about silver it's all about current you
know paper currency you know should they
just give up or you know having a gold
is still important I mean gold and
Bitcoin share this fundamental roots and
time and it's they aren't chiefly
governed by the capital function there
are the capital changes in his volatile
and is thus not a stable source of
measurement and it's time that's a
source of measurement and both gold and
Bitcoin share this feature and gold has
really important value as an insurance
currency you know the internet collapses
or you know there are all sorts of
reasons for gold being important and
gold and bitcoins I think will converge
in value because they both
our intrinsic monetary they're like a
lion's share of the internet yeah right
you want to both my book is going to be
called Bitcoin and gold and I actually
have have made things that are amazing
discoveries to me nobody understood
understood what Newton was doing Isaac
Newton during his 30 years ran the mint
was actually inventing the gold standard
and getting rid of silver and and
creating us a currency that could
sustain the British Empire well and and
hacking gold Newton's alchemy people
this barrage Newton he went crazy became
an alchemist what he was doing was
hacking gold
proving that gold couldn't be reverse
engineered just as all the Bitcoin
hackers of so George I and it was the
anti Alchemist thing yeah you know that
you couldn't make fake gold you guys
write real gold I'm so interesting well
we will leave it there George Gilder who
your latest book is knowledge and power
the information theory of capitalism and
how it is revolutionized revolutionising
our world and you are a Bitcoin
evangelist in the same way that a Isaac
Newton was an evangelist against the
Catholic Church oh yeah you know
whatever is going on whatever wise man
today spent a lot of time calling the
Pope a werewolf and we own the book of
Revelation BAM Bitcoin is the future
says you right I think so
all right very good George Gilder thanks
for talking to Reason TV thank you so
much for reason TV I'm Nichol SP
you